[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening my name is Larry Baca and
as chancellor the institute it's my
pleasure to welcome you all to the
inaugural lecture in the Ford Nobel
laureate lecture series this series will
bring nobel laureates to MIT from
throughout the world to discuss
important work in their fields all the
fields in which nobel prizes are awarded
will be represented in this series
Ford Nobel lectures will be scheduled
throughout the fall and the spring terms
over the next five years we're very
grateful to Ford Motor Company for
sponsoring this series it's part of an
extensive partnership between Ford and
MIT which focuses on research and
education MIT faculty and students are
working collaboratively with Ford in a
variety of fields that encompass
virtually all five of MIT schools we are
collaborating on projects as diverse as
the environment ecommerce combustion
engineering virtual engineering and
virtual education this partnership is
helping to define new models of
university industry collaboration and
we're very proud of it it had been my
plan at this point in the evening to
introduce dr. Martin Zimmerman the vice
president for government affairs at Ford
who is going to introduce our speakers
unfortunately Marty's plane has been
delayed and he'll be joining us later on
in the program so it becomes my pleasure
to introduce our three speakers I've
invited Marty when he gets here to come
up and actually close the program and
thank our panelists since I won't have
an opportunity to properly introduce him
at the time just let me tell you a
little bit about Marty he's an alumnus
of our economics department where he
received his PhD former faculty member
in our Sloan school after which he went
on to become a faculty member at the
Graduate School of Business at the
University of Michigan he's been a
wonderful friend of the Institute and
has played a major role in helping to
create the Ford MIT partnership and
we're very grateful for his help in
sponsoring this event today our three
speakers tonight really need no
introduction
now Marty told me when I spoke to him
earlier today that he once said that
when he was about to introduce
one of his bosses and the response was
well you know that's true but I prefer
if you go ahead and did it anyway
so let me just say a few words about
Paul Samuelson Franco Modigliani and and
Bob Solow if I really tried to describe
all of their honors and awards and
honorary degrees we really wouldn't have
time for the interesting work of this
evening which is their remarks so I will
be brief
professor Samuelson received the Nobel
Memorial Prize in Economic Sciences I
intend
and actively contributed to raising the
level of analyses in economic science
that's a direct quotation from the Nobel
Citation as a Sir Lynn back said in the
presentation speech professor Samuelson
has in fact simply rewritten
considerable parts of economic theory he
has also shown the fundamental unity of
both the problems and annika analytical
techniques in economics any introduction
of professor Samuelson would not be
complete without noting that he is the
author of what I believe is the most
popular textbook in the history of not
just economics but all of American
higher education professor Modigliani
received the Nobel Memorial Prize in
Economic Sciences 85 for quote his
pioneering analyses of savings and
financial markets the achievements for
which he was recognized included the
lifecycle hypothesis of household
savings and for the formulation of the
modigliani-miller theorem of the
valuation of firms and of capital costs
Franco has been a consultant and
involved with governments throughout the
world and we have all been very grateful
for his contributions to our economics
department as with Paul for many many
years
professor solo received the Nobel
Memorial Prize in Economic Sciences
contributions to the theory of economic
growth the Nobel Committee cited the
enormous influence of the solo growth
model and his work on
growth analyses and indeed as we come to
understand the role of technological
change and productivity and the role
that it is playing in our economy today
again we turn to the work of Bob Solow
now the Nobel Prize recognizes the
contributions of these three men to the
field of economic science it really is
awarded for the research but in point of
fact beyond their research each of these
men have made absolutely enormous
contributions to the education of
generations of economists not just at
MIT but throughout the world indeed I
don't think I'm overstating it when I
say that they are least as as loved and
as as well regarded for the wonderful
work they as they have done as members
of our economics faculty as they are for
their contributions to economic science
so tonight they are going to take the
long view both back and forward taking a
look at our economy the last 50 years
and what I'm sure everybody's anxious to
hear their prognostication of the
economy for the next 50 years
please joining me join me again in
welcoming three Giants of our field Paul
Samuelson Franco Modigliani and Bob
Solow
the last time I saw this hall full to
overflowing was when I had the duty to
debate Milton Friedman it was a question
of one lion and one Christian and I will
not tell you which part was mine tonight
I expect to be a piece of cake all I
have to do is to discuss with you the
major economic problems in the upcoming
decade when I first wrote my
best-selling economics textbook at World
War two Zinn I correctly identified what
would be the major economic problem of
the upcoming quarter of a century simply
put it was avoiding the depression
unemployment that blighted the 1930s
that was then now is 2000 my choice now
looking ahead not to a quarter of a
century but just for a decade is what is
a major problem and I believe it to be
how to work out the Aristotelian golden
mean that weighs the delicate compromise
between what we rendered to the market
price mechanism and what we render to
democratic government interferences by
the Democratic welfare state and my
right my remarks build up to that
problem back at the end of World War two
all the standard textbooks were still
stuck in the 1920s orthodoxy of pure
capitalism
I knew that system I grew up under that
system I sold Norman Rockwell Saturday
evening posts there were no unions up up
to the time of my infancy childhood and
since that was the system but after the
Herbert Hoover slump that is the only
partisan remark I will make in the
evening MIT students and college
beginners everywhere needed to learn the
Keynesian macroeconomics that ushered in
a generation of unprecedented global
growth in the third quarter of the 20th
century for better or worse Franklin
Roosevelt's New Deal moved us into a
mixed economy not pure capitalism
certainly not bureaucratic command
communism of the Stalin and Mao type
here at home and similarly abroad almost
everywhere that quasi welfare state
evolved now what does that mean cotton
mean concretely it means most of the
business of the society the economic
business is left to the allocation of
the market price mechanism profit loss
selfishness checks and balances the
first this was so to speak a monday to
friday affair but then on sunday and
increasingly even on saturday democratic
governmental legislate legislatures and
agencies did lean against the wind of
the glaring inequalities generated by
the competitive price property private
property mechanism well how do they lean
against the wind
there wasn't old-fashioned socialism
government ownership of the means of
production it was done as far as the
redistribution of income to attenuate
the worst inequalities which will always
be generated by a less a fair private
profit system that has to be done by the
fiscal system progressive taxation takes
more from the rich than from the poor
redistributed transfer expenditures
unemployment insurance Social Security
poverty and wealth
programs bank deposit insurance give to
the poor and lower-income classes more
than it takes from them by taxes
well I won't use time to describe that
process because you've all lived in that
you were born into it you've grown up
into it however about in the third
quarter of the century towards the last
part of the century a nature cannot
stand relative prosperity and stability
and complacency by the quarter of the
century just ended in much of the world
there's grown up a conservative trend
away from altruism that is a fact about
modern democracy a different fact from
the less a fair Society I'm sorry
from the 1929 drift away from the less a
fair Society and you've seen it all over
the globe you've seen it in presidencies
of Eisenhower Nixon Reagan elder George
Bush even in Scandinavia and continental
Europe social democracies retreated
under attack now let me give you my take
on the two reasons for this it's
axiomatic that always the affluent will
hope to use their money power to resist
populist demands to have the government
help the masses at their expense I'm
speaking of my suburban neighbors people
you all know mostly actually your own
parents
however before Keynes showed us how to
mostly tame depressions the lower
three-quarters of the income classes of
electorate suffered enough to goad them
into opposing the disproportionate
powers in democratic real politic of
private business and of affluence our
system is one knows one vote but our
system of how the votes count is that if
you have lots of dollars in your wallet
your effective voting power will be
greater so in the age after Keynes
discontent atrophied and lobbyists
learned how to operate also many from
even the lowest part of the middle
classes came to overvalue their own
lottery ticket probability of being one
of the rich favored by politics if
you're taking notes I hope you'll
rewrite those tongue-tied last couple of
sentence sentences but there was a
second possible reason for the retreat
from voter imposed alcoholism we do we
do gooders or like Oliver Twist we
always ask for more we are like the boy
who said he could spell banana except
that he didn't know when to stop going
all the way as Lenin Stalin and Mao did
was motivated or said it was motivated
by good if unrealistic intentions but
I'm not speaking of communism and the
recent ending of the Cold War I'm
speaking of societies like those in
Scandinavia in Israel all over the world
once modern democracies began to spend
and organize more than 50% of society's
potential GDP two things seem to begin
to happen now I'm giving you my slant my
reading of
events high tax rates do begin to put
considerable sand in the economic
cogwheels the mathematical economist
discovers that these deadweight losses
against efficiency and growth progress
will increase with the square of the
altruistic scale I'm talking MIT Talk
I do not deny that any noble cause
should be pushed some distance into the
law of diminishing returns but remember
we have only one human nature it's that
which evolved from the Darwinian
struggle for existence and it seems to
have left us all of us with only a
limited endowment of this precious
altruism
so altruism I believe does need to be
rationed carefully precisely because of
its scarcity well that's not all about
big government I started out as a how
shall I describe myself I was trained by
Jesuits at the University of Chicago the
the Cathedral of choice at my University
of Chicago was the Cathedral of free
private enterprise not of the medieval
Catholic Church but once I threw off
that brainwashing because I was like a
sponge I was a very good student so I
was I was a sponge I I reached a
balanced value judgment position now has
it changed my arteries have hardened
have I followed the usual course of
becoming more conservative as I age now
I'm the greatest expert on me so I would
just tell you that I don't detect in
myself very much of a great change in
value judgments however I haven't been
asleep all these years
and it was a great event for me when
Joseph McCarthy undertook a witch hunt
in the United States which reached deep
into every governmental circle deep into
every academic group and I suddenly
realized what one big employer means
when innocent friends of mine were
blackballed and lost their job if we'd
gone all the way if we really were a one
employing company there would be no
place to hide they went to work for
hardware stores one became a treasurer
of Mars candy company there is a a
certain protection for all of the
do-gooder liberal things that I treasure
in not having one big company moreover
and this is an economic finding that I
cannot document precisely but something
seems to happen when even in a very
civilized part of the world like
Scandinavia the part of the GDP that
goes through government hands becomes 50
percent 60 percent when tax rates become
92 percent out of every dollar you don't
teach much night school or summer school
under those conditions it isn't just
that sand in the cogs that I spoke of
earlier but there is something that
becomes unresponsive to human needs in
the decision-making of the lobbyist
politician world that leads me to the
conclusion that whereas I used to in my
MIT class speak of the mixed economy of
the welfare state
I now speak of the limited mixed economy
the limited welfare state and so that
brings me up to the topic that I started
out with what is the best compromise
what are the best limits so that we get
the advantages of the regulatory powers
of democratic government of the
stabilization powers of a Federal
Reserve central bank of a fiscal policy
which leans against the wind when there
are no jobs it's the right thing to
lower taxes it's the right thing to run
deficits but it is not a right thing to
do those same things when we are in a
overheated very high employment economy
now there are no simple rules young
assistant professors will spend their
lifetime in working out documented
progress on that problem and that I
think is the major problem and maybe
some of it will come out in the
discussion that follows thank you
when we drew lots not so long ago the
decision was that Paul would would speak
first that this on this panel and I
second and Franco Modigliani last so
it's my turn now and I'm going to talk
about in a about slightly different
things from what you've just heard from
Paul Samuelson the first thing you
should keep in mind remember what the
the title for this symposium was the
last 50 years and in the next 50 years
you should keep in mind that the years
from 1950 to 2000 were in most economic
ways in this country extraordinarily
successful by the way the period from
1950 to 2000 fits my lifetime very well
1950 was the year in which I finished my
PhD thesis and began teaching at MIT so
the next 50 years will cover roughly the
corresponding period in many of your
lives the next 50 years are the years
between for graduate students in the in
the room between now and when you are
old and doddering like
like us the the the question that that
was rate that that we want to raise that
I want to raise and discuss here is and
you should be thinking about is whether
the next whether you will have it so
good whether the next 50 years can be as
successful as the last I don't want to
bore you with measurements of how much
better or how or how well the country
did in the last 50 years but one one
simple statistic is that real
consumption spending per person in the
population what the average expenditure
on consumer goods and services corrected
for inflation is was in two thousand
three and a half times what it was in in
1950 in measured that way the standard
of living multiplied itself by three and
a half by the way I was a little shocked
to discover that in 1950 almost 15% of
the American workforce was engaged in
agriculture that number is now between
two and and three percent but but
multiplying what the what command over
consumption goods the average person has
by a factor of three and a half is is a
pretty dramatic transformation there
were however failures in that 50-year
period first of all the improvement in
the average standard of living was not
smooth or uniform
there were recessions in 1954 in 1958 in
1960 in 1970 in 1975 in 1980 in 1982 and
in 1991
and you know the standard newspaper
puzzle what is the next term in that
progression you're not gonna learn that
tonight there were also episodes of
inflation during that period output per
hour work productivity of Labor in the
US grew rapidly early in the period and
then slowed down and then may have
speeded up again in the last few years a
more worrying aspect of that last
50-year period was that the amount of
inequality in the distribution of
economic Goods was getting worse it got
the inequality diminished early in that
50-year period and then from about the
mid 1970s turned around and we had a
long spell of widening inequality a
bigger spread between the top and the
bottom earners in the population it
looks as if that worsening inequality
may have stopped in the past two or
three years it's really too soon to know
the data are fragmentary and in any case
there has even in the past two or three
years not been any reversal of a
widening inequality it may be that
between 1950 and 2000 the the incomes
the real incomes of those in the bottom
third of the income distribution may
actually have decreased by the way those
are not the same people the people who
are in the bottom third of the income
distribution in 1950 are not the same
people who were in the bottom third in
2000 but if you think of that as a role
in society being one of the 33% poorest
people in the society then the the real
income associated with that
Rolle has probably actually diminished
in the past in the past 50 years we know
for instance that the earnings premium
associated with higher education has
increased and is still increasing
that's very good four for you and four
for us as a matter of fact the US has
been very successful at higher education
people come from elsewhere to to go to
universities in the u.s. we have not
done very well at educating the less
talented part of the population and the
poor people don't come from far away to
go to urban elementary schools or high
schools in in the u.s. we one of the bad
things about the past 50 years is that
we we risk perpetuating a sort of
permanent underclass well if the period
from 1950 to 2000 was a success and I
think despite the the problems that I've
that I mentioned that success was based
mainly on technological innovation
improvements in economic policy and good
luck in in what proportions it's it's
very hard to say and and and this is in
a way what the poll was was telling you
about some of those many of those
improvements in economic policy are
probably traceable to better economic
analysis to a better understanding of
the way a mixed system like ours works
how about the next 50 years how about
the years when you will be as old as
as the three of us are now no one can
predict what economic life in the u.s.
will be like in in 2050 that's not
because we're bad at predicting it
hasn't been determined yet God hasn't
decided how good things will be in 2050
so how could we possibly know but there
are there are some fairly clear
tendencies that we can talk about for
example the it's not just us but the
population of the u.s. is aging and
that's and that and that's happening
elsewhere in the in the modern
industrial world as well there will be
50 years from now relatively more old
people like us and relatively fewer
young people like you it comes about for
for several reasons first of all because
of increasing longevity also because of
smaller family size there are fewer
children born on the average to each
woman in in modern societies and at the
aging of the population also has to do
with a single historical event the baby
boom the fact that about 1950 in fact
family sizes and the size of a completed
family in in the US and elsewhere in the
in the world began to rise and created a
bulge in the population that bulge like
like a pig swallowed by a snake is sort
of creeping through the body
politic and stop yeah yes I do not
intend to describe the end of that
process but before before 2050 the the
baby boom will have retired and and this
very important fact that the population
is getting relat relat of lis older is
unlikely to be reversed anytime soon
immigration is an offset to the aging of
the population immigrants tend to be
younger and more fertile not more
children than the resident Americans but
emigration is unlikely to occur in
anything like large enough numbers to
reverse the process why is the aging of
the population important it's important
because the working age population
shrinks as a proportion of of the total
population if we want to look at the
standard of living at income per person
in the population we can describe that
as the product of two numbers income per
worker and the number the ratio of
workers to population and if the second
of those factors get smaller as it
undoubtedly will the the standard of
living will tend to suffer unless
something else happens unless the
average standard of living will fall
unless compared with what with what it
would have been without this aging
process unless something happens to
change it there we will simply have
fewer producers relative to the number
of consumers
there'll be non-economic consequences of
the aging of the population as well
their nursing homes are going to be more
popular than nursery schools
speaking and voters voting will change
old voters are different from young
voters by the way you want to keep in
mind that this fact that I'm I've been
describing to you is to a first
approximation only to a first
approximation independent of social
security arrangements
Franco unless I miss my guess will want
to talk to you a bit about Social
Security but the main function of the
Social Security system is to determine
how much of the national pie goes to the
old folks and how they financed their
access to their share of the national
pie but what there is to divide in any
decade in the decade from 2040 to 2050
for instance is what is produced in that
decade the Social Security rules don't
directly affect that affect that but
they do indirectly they do because the
social security rules influence
retirement decisions they may provide
incentives to retire earlier or later
older retirement would relieve the aging
problem in fact in recent years the age
of retirement has decreasing not only in
the US but elsewhere in the industrial
world as well and that reinforces the
effect of an aging population the real
offset to having a smaller working
population is higher productivity we
know that output per hour worked will be
higher in 2050 than it is now an
important question is whether
productivity growth can be accelerated
as a matter of policy sort of as a
conscious decision of the society the
answer to that is probably yes although
it is really impossible to be
quantitative about it and that brings me
to a question that I think you would
like to talk about and I don't like to
talk about
the question that you read in the
newspapers or on the web or wherever are
we on the verge of or are we already
into some sort of new Industrial
Revolution a new economy that will make
the kinds of mundane considerations that
I've been talking about obsolete a
simpler question is whether the
acceleration of productivity that that
has happened between 1995 and this year
and 2000 whether that acceleration is
sustainable for the next 50 years by the
way even the rate of productivity growth
between 1995 and 2000 is not noticeably
faster than it was between 1950 and and
1972 in round numbers output per hour
worked in the u.s. rose but at a rate
between one and one and a half percent a
year in the years between 1972 and 1995
and in the five years or four years
between 1995 and 1999 it rose at between
two and three percent a year and even
faster so far in 2000 that's a big
difference it seems like a small
difference those productivity go up at
1% a year or 2% a year or 2% a year or
3% a year but over a 50 year period 1
percent productivity growth increases
productivity by 65 percent roughly 2
percent by a hundred and 70 percent and
3 percent by 338 percent so what you
will be able to consume per person on
the average in 2000 really depends in a
big way on a percent here and a percent
there in the annual rate of productivity
increase we'll the good fortune of the
last few years continued I don't know
extrapolating from four or five years of
observation to 50 years is not a
comfortable
activity it helps if you can look a
little deeper we can look a little
deeper but the observational basis is
still very slim Mark Twain
Mark Twain said in life on the
Mississippi isn't science wonderful you
get such a lot of conjecture on such a
small allowance of fact and we don't
we're lacking a good empirical basis for
for trying to extrapolate productivity
increase one serious investigation
I know shows that outside of durable
goods manufacturing outside of that part
of the economy that that makes durable
goods there has been practically no
technological no improvement in pure
productivity during the past five years
and interestingly enough about 80
percent of the investment in information
technology goes outside of durable goods
manufacturing there is outside of the of
that part of manufacturing the there's
very small increment of productivity
growth and it is over accounted for by
the sheer capital investment and
improved educational status of the
workforce so there's not much left to be
accounted for by improved improved
technology this suggests to me that we
will be lucky to achieve the same gains
in the standard of living in the next 50
years that we did in the past 50 years
we would need faster productivity growth
than in the past 50 years to offset the
drag from aging I think there's an a
chance that we'll get it but there is
really no certainty nothing remotely
like certainty that we will get a lot
more what this suggests to me is that we
need to pursue technological improve
when not merely in information
technology but in other fields as well
it might be a good idea if somebody
majored in something other than the EECS
wants to know why that that still leaves
us with inequality and the problem of
the unskilled and uneducated even
suppose that we can we can manage and
accelerate the acceleration productivity
that will offset the drag that comes
from an older population we would still
have that problem of dealing with the
unskilled and uneducated the next 50
years a period if it is a period of
rapid technological innovation could
make that problem worse unless we find
some way of tackling the problems of the
bottom third of the income distribution
it's not clear that we have either ideas
new ideas or any willingness to do
something about there about that and I
will leave it there and turn the floor
over to my colleague motor yeah
[Applause]
when I was asked to join Paul and Bob on
this occasion I immediately thought or
remembered a famous line from my great
poet than Alighieri the great poet of
Italy who tells how he got into the
beginning of the inferno and there he
was met he was lost and it was met by
Virgil and while they were talking in
King of honor and then tanta says and I
was third among such genius I hope I can
keep it up that's in first of all let me
say that I had the privilege of
suggesting the title for tonight because
I thought that I wanted to be sure
everybody would be interested now
everybody here must be either interested
or have lived the last 50 years
or must expect to live the next 50
everybody should be vote next let me say
that in general I have developed ideas
similar to those above and I generally
agree with his analysis and his
conclusions so let me stress the few
points where I had something to add and
they say they are not that many one
thing is that they will point out we
have seen that the last 50 years have
been exceptional in terms of growth have
been have seen people getting a lot
better off and on Fletcher I want to
point out that in effect there is a
group of people that they didn't better
and that is our age group we were
particularly fortunate because we had in
addition to this growth in productivity
we had three things working for us first
a stock market boom we find that our
wealth has been multiplied without our
doing anything
I never expected that I would have so
much wealth as I end up having it's
completely beyond my wildest thoughts
whatever I didn't put or we didn't put
in the stock market we put into the
other state and that is just as much
again pure luck was not many now there
is a slight difference that of the whole
the real estate has a reason for rising
because land is fixed and population is
expanding and income is expanding
therefore the value of land particularly
urban land must enter eyes there is a
good reason in the case of the stock
market Illyria isn't any good reason and
I think and I have said many times that
much of what is going on in the stock
market reflects a bubble not entirely
not entirely that is let me put it this
way the price of the share can be seen
as depending on the profit in urns
multiplied by the profit earnings ratio
how much and price in English what is
the price per dollar
so no dollar earned times price earnings
gives you the price of the share now
what is happen in this period is that
both the Earthlings have grown rapidly
and the price earnings have gone up and
the growth of the earnings is partly
deflection of this very sound economy
it's a reflection of the productivity
and reflection of many things and rather
a questioned labor
behavior which is sort of allowed of
this but the rise in the price earning
ratio which keeps going on is not of
this kind that is the bubble there is no
reason why as long as the earnings
Cluett the concentrate there is no
reason why the price earning ratio
should rise
if it rises it is because of the bubble
and what's a bubble it's a situation
where a price a ridiculously high price
is justified by the fact that everybody
expects that the next price next year
would be even higher so no matter how
ridiculous it is as long as it keeps
rising it's justified and this by the
way one learns from both work some
expense and the proper is that as if the
process continues and the price
continues to rise it justifies the price
but the price gets more and more
ridiculous it gets more and more out of
line with reality and we economists
always think of him seen in a famous
example they so called to deepen bomb
boom or bubble were too deep suddenly
where the price of two leaders went up
many many hundreds of time and there was
no good reason
eventually the thing collapsed because
at some point people think the price is
ridiculously high and they do not
willing to bitten any higher and then it
stops growing when it stops growing it
cannot hold collapses so I think that's
that bubble is has been made ostrich and
may present the problem for you from now
on into the future because I think at
some point that we're going to be in the
alignment the case some extent it will
be true in real estate piece of absolute
luck that we have had completely
undeserved is Medicare Medicare is being
paid by the young thought the old when
we were young we didn't pay because
Medicare didn't exist so we you are
paying for us and the expectation that
somebody will pay for you if we never
paid anything and we got an incredible
boon just as we were getting old in the
need a medic and so these three things
are very hard to reproduce
now the however we have done so well and
some of this as I say is not
reproducible so I agree with Bob that
you are not likely to do quite as well
no matter what well as well as some of
us has done now of course because of we
are unexpectedly rich we may be leaving
you young people larger the inheritance
that we might have done otherwise and
they will help you to some extent will
carry over but not completely
now the have to have that this great
developments in this country still is
somewhat unique because there are the
major competitors they have a part of
the world that has a similar capacities
similar qualities of Labor capital etc
is Europe and Europe is not doing
anywhere as well and why aren't they
doing as well well first of all
objectively Europe still has something
like 10% 11% unemployment with average
unemployment rate it depends it varies
from one country to another but the
average is still 11% and furthermore the
way they are moving they are not going
not like to cut that down quickly they
are very happy when they grow 3% and 3%
is not much to cut into the other plan
just enough to absorb the productivity
and population growth now why are they
doing so badly well I think the answer
is Paul did it before because they do
not read kids they refuse to understand
Keynes they are stupid enough so that
they will not read and understand
not enough money in the economy you have
an employment okay so they keep a policy
which is wrong and they keep it
continuously even to the present time we
just have an example with with 10
percent unemployment the central bank
raises interest rates without
understanding that the way to cut
unemployment is the American Way invest
invest invest that's why we are doing so
well that's why they are doing so poorly
that's by the way exactly what Keynes
said investment is what determines
income okay that's a main determinant
now it can be made up by government or
private here in this country fortunately
it's mostly private investment that's
entirely but that is what is driving us
so high and that's what in the way of
Europe
I do hope that at some point they will
learn case they still is hope I have
been fighting my way but you know I have
just a couple of months ago he wrote a
paper explaining this and some one of my
colleagues said poor Modigliani he still
believes in case that's a European
mentality which apply to a guy you never
understood kids
now as we look ahead into the future
aside from these known advantages there
are some definite problems to worry
about and I would like to mention some I
mean first of all there is the fact of
the Wall Street bubble that one is when
the bubble explodes is expect they will
be unpleasant consequences in the
economy they will be very likely some
decrease in demand because consumption
will decrease you keep reading
everywhere about the wealth effect
consumption is so high because of the
wealth effect you seldom see a footnote
that says that is to be found for the
first time in Modigliani's life cycle
that's where the word was first
mentioned in 1950s now it's become very
popular but that effect certainly I'm
sure that is an important thing that has
supported our boom although more than
supporting our boom it has done
something that's not so good create a
large deficit in the balance of payment
remember that that is a problem we have
a gigantic net we have a gigantic annual
deficit that is we spend more than we
earn
we use more resources than we produce
them okay now one has to be careful in
distinguishing whether having a deficit
or being in debt is bad per se from the
size the fact of being in that is not
per se
band or in that'sit think of anybody
like you in your age group you are maybe
who be buying a house in the year in
which you buy a house your income is a
thousand and you spend twenty thousand
so you have you have terrific deficit
and you go into that is that bad no
because against that you have an asset
the same thing is true in this country
we borrow but we borrow to invest so
essentially against them the debt we do
have earning assets and there is nothing
per se wrong with borrowing the problem
is that if you go too far then the
creditors may begin to me to get worried
okay yeah you're investing but look at
how big your debt is it's something go
wrong you will be unable to pay and
that's the the danger will we face in
our balance of payment that it is
conceivable that at some point
foreigners will refuse to continue to
lend us or to buy the shares of our
companies to provide the capital because
they had enough and if that happens and
if they want to stop bringing in money
and the dollar might begin to stop
appreciating and might begin to
depreciate then they may be wrong
everybody may want to get out of the
dollar before the depreciation and then
the United States is no different from
Malaya or from Singapore Singapore did
all right but any of the states of the
governments that appear to be in
complete disarray because with fruit
exchanges if people wanna get out there
is nothing you can do itself less the
currency the value let's say only you
have to let it go when that happens you
have inflation you have inflation the
central bank will raise interest rates
like like the total investment will
decline and we could have serious
consequences including
contributing to the stock market crash
because there's people get out there
what who sell the shares they own and
have additional pressure so that complex
are very high I mean penny high stock
prices bubble the deficit in the balance
of payment is a complex that could
generate some serious problems in the
future
it need not that is it is possible that
things would sort of quite down but the
main way in which we could help the
situation would be by saving more
because if we save more we can serve
those investment we can finance those
investment without the need to borrow
abroad so that would be a very desirable
thing now just let me come to another
problem which i think is a part of the
long view and then is what bob has
mentioned the problem of social security
we do know that we have a system of
social security which is called
pay-as-you-go a system in which the
pensions are not paid out of the
accumulation that you've made in the
normal system or in my life cycle people
accumulate wealth and they use that
wealth to live when they are old okay to
essentially be their pension the present
system is instead you do not build up
and wealth you take the money that is
contributed by people and instead of
fully design you use it to pay pensions
so there is no accumulation now that has
several consequences one consequence is
that the system is unstable because
the relation between contribution and
pensions depends on how fast economy
grows if the economy grows fast then you
can get out more than you put in because
there are more people to pay with their
contribution than they were when you
started so you can get more money than
you could put in but if you're promised
a certain return that's like an implicit
interest rate let's have to return if
the growth changes then you cannot
deliver the promises and what's happened
in this country and throughout most of
the world is that as population growth
declines you cannot fulfill those
promises because the ratio of people
that pay contribution to those who get
pensions changes and deteriorates they
have less and less people paying to a
person even imagine that is sure to
create problems now how much and how bad
will depend on what we do about it
the present the administration has no
program to handle it that is it will put
in throw in the surplus of the budget to
support Social Security but that will
not get you beyond the middle of the
next century by that time approximately
they will have to be something like a
50% increase in the dues in the what you
have to pay in the payroll tax or a cart
in benefits and here is the point where
I have something to offer I've been
working now for a couple of years on
finding a solution to this problem and
find that the solution exists and it's
really rather simple the solution
consists in creating a so-called
founded system I found
system is one in which the contributions
instead of being used to pay pensions
are used to accumulate a wealth and then
when you retire that wealth and not the
young people because that wealth pays
your pension
now once you have been able you've made
the change you can see that this system
is far burned because in the first place
it is cheaper we have figured out that
under the page you go by 2050 or
thereafter he will have to pay about 20%
21% contribution he said with the 12 or
today with our system he would pay only
about 7% so be able to cut get over the
crisis and cut contributions very
substantial wealth and furthermore a
founded system is less sensitive to
variations in people in in growth it's
completely and when largely unaffected
by population growth because population
affects the picture because the young
support the old when they old are
supported by their caravel they don't
care how many young people's are are now
you have to understand the moment how
that fits into the picture that bob has
given and which is very commonly
accepted the idea is that how can you
avoid getting poorer or paying less
pensions if you have less people more
old people to supply because he says
that's the pie if you got more for them
you got less favelas well the answer is
that under our system the pie is not
fixed the pie is precisely the penance
on what you need if you have many old
people you will have a large
accumulation from the past
which will take care of this they may be
to the point where the accumulation the
fund will be decreasing because they'll
pay out more than gets but that's all
right
paying out warning get simply means that
they will be liquidating some assets
society as a whole which is not growing
we need less assets anyway so the thing
will be largely taken on itself so this
is I think a kind of possibility that
gives us hope I mean obviously I don't
have time to go to details but I will I
should have brought with me the website
where you can find this by the way I can
tell you if you look handily in the
website and the MIT and the Franco
Modigliani you will find there that
there is a latest version of my plan
thank you
there Thanks there there are a couple of
microphones set up at least in that
aisle and in that aisle I can't see if
they're I think those are all that there
is but but we're happy to have some
conversation with anyone who has a
question or a pronouncement or a theorem
pronouncement in this group a question
to both all the panel has to do with
aging and also your solution dr. vinet
it seems as if you're making an
assumption that the aging will have an
effect which is bad you were mentioning
that retirement age is going down rather
than up you know but look at the three
of you in many cut parts of the United
States at least people may have retired
but they may also still be working the
fact of people being of older people
being healthier and healthier I wonder
if it's it really and I just don't know
if you know I'm just asking cuz I don't
know has there been any work done to
really try to quantify that aging effect
and then this well I'll look at your
website for the second question let me I
think there is a little allusion here
that is shared always by people like us
by us I mean everyone here in this room
we're people who on the whole or let me
back up a minute and say one obvious way
of for a society to deal with this aging
fact
demography is to is to prolong the
working life just as was just said we
all we're living longer were living or
having healthier old age why should not
the working life be prolonged
people like us who like our work who
rather don't like the notion of retiring
we want to hang on to the office and
continue to to work it seems a little
more obvious than it is the society is
full of people who do dull work and
don't like it and they will not be happy
to be tired that well the way we deal
with this is for you instead of retiring
at 65 were more likely 62 or 61 as you
at plan you will of course use your
healthy years being a clerk in a
department store for another five or ten
years or for doing one or another kind
of work that's not so pleasant and not
so rewarding I think it's inevitable
actually that the the working life will
be prolonged in the US and elsewhere
simply because people live longer an RL
theatre and and the way to to deal with
the productivity problem that emerges is
to prolong the age of retirement I think
the scheme that Franco was describing
the the connection between what he was
saying and what I was saying is that
this extra accumulation of capital that
comes with a funded system is precisely
what gives you the extra productivity
exact that's needed to support exactly
its population a smaller fraction is
working the it the amount of work
performed by the population measured in
hours will diminish the
the decreasing age of retirement is not
an illusion for people like us it is but
for people who in automobile factories
and now live in RVs recreational
vehicles in Florida it is not the case
so something like the extra capital
accumulation is what we need Frank oh
did you want to add something just and
one thing first of all that every
thinking person agrees that the list you
want to do is you want to give
incentives to work longer whether or not
to make it mandatory you want to give
incentives and that's not an obvious
thing to me let me remind you of the
example of the folly of my foreign my
former country Italy where the reasoning
was once you retire you have a pension
you shouldn't work anymore because the
otherwise you get richer therefore if
you work will tax it heavily that's
completely the wrong reasoning if you
work the fact that you get richer fine
that's your incentive to work longer so
that's exactly we should provide that
kind of thing we might also have some
shift in the age in the standard age
which would retire in order to maintain
the relation between see this is
particularly important with respect to
life expectancy because aside from the
getting older because of the smaller
number of births you also have the fact
that longevity is increasing and the
jail increasing requires additional
contributions and so forth and one way
to cut that is by lengthening the buy
time the retirement age to life
expectancy try the other Michaels
mr. mark professors so took about the
success of American economics and
sustainability of rapid growth in
productivity this is to me a global
question the model that was taught to
the world by Ford beginning of the
century and by the Americans sight in
its wall is mulleted sustained by a very
high level of consumption of goods
personal transportation that is car
versus bus and the production of short
lasting products instead of quality
products from what America is the first
country in the world as number of cars
per capita that is a success but even
the most polluting comes in the world in
terms of amount of energy that's used
per capita my question is now what will
lap in the next decade next 50 years
when energetic research will be more
crucial and costly and when some rapidly
growing countries is China for instance
will ask for the same level of welfare
of us what will happen to global
economics at that point and the second
question that one can be down what can
be done to develop a sustainable
economic model in the next five years
Paul you are well
one person one question it is obviously
the case that the u.s. with its early
high standard of living has been
plundering the exhaustive and exhausting
resources at a much faster rate and if
we are successful in other parts of the
world in raising levels of sanity living
to the u.s. level that will mean a
billion Chinese are plundering at the
American rate a billion Indians will be
plundering at that rate scientists will
always be finding new resources and in
the age after neutral probably
scientists can do a lot of winning of
the battle but there still is second law
of thermodynamics and there still is
some limitation and so it will become
very important not to have SUVs versus
efficient cars just because people want
them and this is one of those places
where you can't believe it too less a
fair because if it's left to less a
ferret I warn s you'll be all heaven s
you'll be but my freedom ends where your
nose begins as I swing my cane and
[Laughter]
we're all breathing the same molecules
George's Caesar died and I'm breathing
some of his his molecules so we really
are interdependent and I think there
will have to be in 2050 when instead of
our having 23% of world output with only
5% of the population we will have
something like 9 percent of we're
allowed output and there will be a lot
more demands on it and so this doesn't
mean that we can't use a pricing system
we actually are using the pricing system
to ration out pollution but we can't
rely only on the pricing system we need
the common rule of the road professor
Samuelson in particular but any of you
who would care to answer I didn't hear
any of you speak of the interaction
between on the one hand globalization
which I think does bring what you were
speaking of professor Santos and the
bigness being the enemy in some sense
and the interplay between that and
democratic institutions which are very
much more yeah on a different scale and
no longer related in any direct way I
thought meeting with students
someone might bring up the question that
was bothering the mob in Seattle who
were protesting against the World Trade
Organization because the low prices at
which I can buy at Walmart are as low as
they are because somebody in China is
making a very low low wage and this
takes me back to an an election in 1962
in Massachusetts there was a professor
Stuart Hughes who was a very liberal
professor of history
ran for Senate and he ran against Teddy
Kennedy the reactionary and and he was
in favor Hughes friend of mine but not a
student of mine he was in favor of a
seven dollar minimum wage at that time
at that time I was about two dollars he
multiplied it by a couple and I and I
said to him you know the traffic won't
bear this we won't be competitive with
other countries he said you were to
understand Samuelson I'm for a seven
dollar minimum wage every place in the
world
and I said to him that is the cruelest
remark I have heard in all of my long
lifetime because a $7 1962 real minimum
wage US purchasing power would have
cause of the 5 million 5 billion people
then alive about forbidden to die of
unemployment and starvation
so the wreck was a problem this is what
makes economists such awful people even
awful to your own children you say these
practical things what you have to ask is
not do I want a poor little girl 12
years old in China to be getting the
wage that Walmart eventually pays and of
course the answer is almost nobody but a
few say this would want that but what
are the alternatives if you don't have
globalization
how has Africa fared being outside of
the globalization system what converted
Hobbs jungle when life was short nasty
and brutish into the present world
it was Newton the age after Newton and
there is no way that the consumers of
Walmart given their quantum of altruism
are going to give up their comfortable
standard of living in order to have a
unilateral transfer gift to those
workers and so you have to ask yourself
in the next 10 years will the emerging
market countries have a upward trend in
real wage for their people earned by
their people in the in the exchange
system or not and
a simple-minded support of globalization
under all conditions is wrong but a
simple-minded rejection of it now I said
I was going to be nonpartisan but I do
have to say I don't agree with candidate
Buchanan I I have a question for a
professor in order to yani um you talked
about changing the pension system from
the current system to a system where you
fund basically your pensions through
through time you start investing them
now one of the places where you would
invest those pensions would be the stock
market and earlier in your remarks you
talked about
so the irrationality that's inherent in
the stock market currently yes so I'm
wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit on what how how you would
insulate it what how you'd insulate the
funds for those pensions from the stock
market volatility and how you and make
sure that people actually do get their
money at the end of their lives
first of all let's be clear that in my
system all the money that's contributed
goals not into your own portfolio it
goes into a common portfolio the idea to
be nonpartisan a president of Bush that
it should go into your own portfolio is
completely wrong because it makes Social
Security into a gambling casino okay
exactly what
you are forced to say you should know
what comes out and that requires defined
benefits now how do I invest the money
that's accumulated essentially in a
portfolio that mimics the economy
composed of the same way as the market
now that doesn't prevent the market from
some movements and right now it's too
high the specific problem that it is now
too high I handled the following way
before my deform was accepted there'll
be plenty of time for the bubble to
deplete then well is deflate that we
will invest I'd like to come back to the
globalization topic the the reason at
least from my point of view is that many
of the products you can buy in Walmart
are so cheap is because well wages are
very low in in developing countries but
the reason for that is is in large part
because of repressive government such as
in Indonesia and or in Latin America for
example and the US and Europe to some
extent supports these governments
actually nurtures these governments
because usually corporations get a
higher yield out of a dictatorship so in
a sense there is some unfairness there
because these repressive governments
actually well they attack unions and
they attack labor movements and so this
is actually a very unfair form reason
why these wages are so low because
because the labor power of labor in
these countries is very weak and and
because of violence and I'd like to know
hear what you have to say about that
well let me take a shot at that I want
to separate two things the fundamental
reason why wages are low in developing
countries is because productivity
in those countries that's far more if if
you were to if you were to classify the
poor countries the or all the countries
of the world in terms of the degree of
democracy that's available the
correlation between that and earning
power is very small the fundamental
reason for the poverty of underdeveloped
undeveloped countries is their low
productivity bad governance
dictatorships tyrannies of one kind or
no there surely make things worse but if
we're going to be deal rationally with
the world economy we have to distinguish
between the globalization in the sense
of open trade where possible migration
possibilities free movement of capital
from places where there's a lot of it to
places where there's a little of it that
has to be distinguished from
dictatorship tyranny lack of democracy
from my own point of view I think that
that over the past 50 years American
foreign policy has been much too
tolerant of of dictatorships and
repressive governments in the third
world and I have certainly and I imagine
all of us here have opposed that
politically but the the step from that
to saying one ought to restrict trade
with poor countries is a bad step it's
an illogical step it's generally it's
the representatives of workers in poor
countries who want
and trade not oppose it so I think we
should try to keep the political side of
this from the economic side of it
separate intellectually because
otherwise it's not possible to think
rationally about those those things I
would not minimize the harmful effects
upon future standards of living of
repressive government be very difficult
in a Nigeria even though it had oil in
the Congo rich with the metals to
develop at all
and when colonial powers moved out at
the beginning they were not repressive
governments but without the repressive
governments they didn't spring instantly
into high wage countries if you just
begin the process and the international
division of labor can help when there
isn't repressive government and it won't
help much where there is such repressive
government that nobody feels secure in
doing any savings nobody gets the result
of their productivity there's no way of
sending students to get advanced
training so there always are an eclectic
number of explanations to each each
problem that that's why economics is
boring but to me that's why it's
interesting faster slow this is mostly
for you with the new productivity
numbers between two and three percent
annually
you see is a correct defensive position
on interest rates which is currently at
650 but historically speaking that's
overinflated was your opinion about
interest rates here in the US or well
the the Federal Reserve the central bank
in the US has I think in formulating and
executing monetary policy been well
aware and reflective about the growth of
productivity they may occasionally have
been over optimistic in fact but on the
whole I think that as are you ready for
a complicated answer there is there is a
real danger that a real possibility I
think that we are managing this period
of rapid expansion with little or no
inflation as a result of an unexpected
acceleration of productivity which has
not been fully reflected in wages and
therefore in and therefore prices are
able to move along at a relatively low
level I think the the Fed has performed
extraordinarily well in in seeing that
this lucky period if it's luck is
translated into high employment and
increasing production they are they are
nervous as we're all nervous that the
timing when this this particular lucky
period ends the timing is going to be
very difficult to to get right
so hold your breath can I just add a
word to this I think the Federal Reserve
on the home has done a really excellent
job they may have been lucky to some
extent but they have shown the right
mixture of courage and restraining quite
good and I think when I said before that
Europe has a lot of unemployment and
they don't understand Kings one of the
manifestation of this is that the
European Central Bank has only one
instruction avoid inflation whereas the
American Constitution says see the way
that output is large as possible subject
to the condition that there should be
minimum inflation and that makes a great
difference and I think we see that
obviously being pursued here and see the
policy are saying no inflation leads to
a very tight and high unemployment
because then you're sure if you've got
20% unemployment then you don't have to
worry about inflation I'm afraid we're
going to have to to stop now and
although my understanding is there's
going to be some food and drink outside
after we're done and I at least then I
imagine my colleagues are happy to stand
around and chat some more
but the introductions are going to go in
a flow uphill here I would like to
introduce to you Marty Zimmerman who is
the vice president for government
relations of the Ford Motor Company is a
PhD in economics from from this
institution and is in large part
responsible for the program of which
this evening is start Marty
Peggy Bob I was hoping you wouldn't
introduce me and then I could use my
line Allah Admiral Stockdale Who am I
and what am I doing here but but having
introduced me I just want to express my
thanks to the panel to Professor
Samuelson Solo and Modigliani for a
really interesting evening
I'm thrilled personally to be part of
this as Professor solo has said I was a
student mid-century mid-century in terms
of the between the 50 and the 2000
period and I derive tremendous benefits
from studying from these gentlemen I
think we all got a taste
tonight of what an enriching experience
that was and I don't mean solely in
Franco's terms that we all found
ourselves wealthier in the year 2000
although is the developer of the
lifecycle hypothesis do you feel that
you consume too little anyway Ford Motor
Company outside but Ford Motor Company
is really delighted to be able to
sponsor this series of Nobel laureates I
think this was a a terrific kickoff I
hope but doubt that we'll be able to
sustain this level of quality as well as
we go through this series this is one
part and really a small part of a very
deep and evolving relationship between
Ford Motor Company by the way when I
come to Cambridge it always helps
recognition if I mentioned that for
Dawn's Volvo so that's
but it is really only one part of a as I
said a deep and evolving relationship
involving research and teaching which
I'm excited about we are I know it Ford
we're very excited about it and I
believe our counterparts here at MIT are
excited because we've done some great
things and we look forward to doing even
greater things in the future my second
role tonight is to tell you that there
is a reception outside since we've had
such a tremendous turnout and in fact I
was told there were overflow crowds in
several parts of campus we've moved the
reception outside I trust the weather is
cooperating so again thank you all for
coming and again thank you to the
panelists for a chilly
[Applause]